Venezuela's political crisis is in a
dangerous new phase a disputed election
could grant the ruling party almost
unlimited power at least 10 people died
in yesterday's violence including at
least one candidate anti-government
protests that started in April have
killed more than 120 people the
country's divided of a president Nicolas
Maduro effort to rewrite the
Constitution the vote yesterday chose an
assembly to start that process
critics say the country appears headed
for a dictatorship and wellbore cos is
in Caracas Venezuela with the growing
constitutional emergency Manuel good
morning good morning this is the
aftermath of yesterday's violence the
u.s. is vowing sanctions on Venezuela as
early as today that newly elected 545
seat assembly will have sweeping powers
to rewrite the Constitution no
opposition members were among the more
than 5,000 names on the ballot further
dividing this polarized nation
police and protesters battled as they
have for months in the streets of
Venezuela demonstrators believe the
election continues to hurtle the country
toward dictatorship with president
Nicolas Maduro and his socialist party
at the helm what do you say about this
election for our computer man I mean
constitutional fraud protesters like
Juan Carlos Gutierrez say they were
threatened with 10 years in jail if
caught marching the streets we have a
little piece of democracy and the
government is killing off at all by
rewriting the Constitution absolutely
voting sites at largely empty across the
country as many Venezuelans who favor
the opposition stayed away from the
polls others like Yvonne Nava took to
the streets instead
even as gunfire was heard nearby the
shoot right now crazy man we're living a
dictatorship I know
the National Police were targets to this
explosion injured seven officers on
motorcycles maduro supporters called the
protesters terrorists so you want some
law and order piece bus is located
that's what you want
bus falling oil prices coupled with
skyrocketing inflation have crippled
Venezuela's economy oil accounts for
nearly half of the government's revenue
and Venezuela is the third largest
supplier of oil to the US which buys
about a third of the country's crude why
are you out here today young Venezuelans
like Deana Osuna say they just want
their voices heard you feel like you
don't have what what do you want what
you deserve what's that that Liberty
what you want to do what you really want
to do freedom yes you don't feel you
have it no we don't president Maduro
declared a sweeping victory hours after
the polls closed claiming eight million
Venezuelans voted for the Assembly but
the opposition believes that number is
much lower in fact less than three
million we expect to see more marches
and clashes today the turmoil here only
likely to continue Manuel Bojorquez in
Venezuela thank you